un couvre-feu élargie et ciblées c'est
la stratégie que pourrait adopter le
gouvernement afin de faire face à
l'épidémie
réunis lors d'un conseil de défense en
visioconférence mardi les membres de
l'exécutif souhaite éviter un nouveau
confinement
mais face à la progression du virus de
nouvelles restrictions devraient être
annoncées pour le début de l'année 2021
invité du journal de 20h sur france 2
olivier vers ans a détaillé la stratégie
du gouvernement ce que nous écartons
c'est l'idée du confinement
nous ne voulons pas confiné à ce stade
annie agopian généraliser ni un
confinement local ak en revanche nous
allons proposer une extension du
couvre-feu qui au lieu de démarrer à 20h
démarrera à 18h dans l'ensemble des
territoires dans lesquels cela s'avérera
nécessaire et régions situées à
l'instant à la totalité de ces régions
des départements ou des métropoles de
ces régions dans lesquelles le taux
d'incidence serait au dessus du seuil
d'alerté maximale et ces mesures seront
applicables à partir du 2 janvier
cette mesure pourrait s'appliquer à une
vingtaine de départements
particulièrement touchés dans les
régions grand test bourgogne franche
comté auvergne rhône-alpes et
provence-alpes-côte d'azur
olivier verrons a également précisé que
la campagne de vaccination doit
s'accélérer à partir de la fin du mois
de janvier
une intervention qui a du mal à
convaincre dans les rangs de
l'opposition et la logique infernale des
restrictions continue s'aggrave
couvre-feu à 18 heures avant leur
confinement ce dossier ans pour
impressionner les naïfs et mise en cache
des français vers ans au 20h des
protocoles sanitaires renforcés à
l'école dans les commerces des
entreprises un vrai traçage et isolement
une vraie campagne de vaccination mais
non voyons un couvre-feu à 18 heures
avec ça on est parti pour deux ans de
kobe 19 encore les sous-doués déception
à la suite de l'intervention d'olivier
ferrand on espérer une accélération de
la vaccination disponibles et de
meilleurs contrôles aux frontières
on nous propose une avancée du
couvre-feu à 18h à géographie variable
dont l'efficacité sanitaire n'est pas
établie avec 11 1395 cas détectés ce
mardi la france reste encore éloigné de
l'eau
objectif gouvernemental de 5000 cas
quotidien olivier verrons a donc rappelé
que même si des aménagements pourraient
être étudiées la levée des restrictions
toujours en place n'est pas encore à
l'ordre du jour